i've always said to the house
that any curbs on our freedoms must be
an absolute last resort
and that we shouldn't keep them in place
for a day longer than absolutely
necessary
with this in mind we've been reviewing
the isolation period for positive cases
to make sure the measures we have in
place
maximize activity in the economy and
education for example but also minimize
the risk of infectious people leaving
isolation
uk hsa data shows
that around two-thirds of positive cases
are no longer infectious by the end of
day five
and we want to use the testing capacity
that we've built up
to help these people leave isolation
safely
after reviewing all of the evidence
we've made the decision to reduce the
minimum self-isolation period to five
full days in england
from monday
people can test twice before they go
leaving isolation at the start of day
six
these two tests are critical to to these
balanced
and proportional plans and i'd urge
everyone to take advantage of the
capacity we have built up in tests so
that we can restore the freedoms to this
country while we are keeping everyone
safe
mr deputy speaker
we've now entered the third year of this
country's fight against covert 19
and thanks to an incredible national
endeavor
we're now better protected than ever
before
but this virus is not going away
there will be more variants
and no one can be sure what threat they
might pose
but we can be sure
that our pharmaceutical defenses
vaccines testing and antivirals are the
best way to protect our health
and our freedoms as we learn to live
with covid i commend this statement to
the house